meteorologists fox and friends host uh
janice dean is back with us this is very
personal for you and again i
i'm sorry about everything you and your
whole family
have have gone through janice there's a
lot happening a lot of moving parts
tonight
we know that the biden department of
justice has launched a criminal
investigation this on top of the
a.g of new york saying publicly it looks
like
50 percent of cases were covered up
support growing to impeach andrew cuomo
one new york democrat saying he was
threatened that cuomo said he'd destroy
him if he didn't go along
and uh a lot going on here and
i wanted to get your reaction all of
this and how far will you take this
well the walls seem to be closing in
finally after
almost a year of uh looking at this
governor
blaming everyone else for his march 25th
order
and now covering up the numbers uh who
knew that andrew cuomo was going to be
the person to bring both republicans and
democrats together
yeah you know you look at this um
what what do you think is most important
you were directly impacted here two
members of your family you lost
in nursing homes as a result of i
believe this executive order
although he denies you know does it
matter we actually said at one point
does it really matter whether you die
here or die there you're dead
uh which was kind of cold i thought
but my question to you is what would you
like to see
somebody who's been directly impacted by
this whose family's been impacted by
this what would you like to see happen
i want to see the investigation and i
want to see
a court of law and i want to see the
governor and his health department his
health commissioner
and his administration on the stand to
tell the whole truth and nothing but the
truth
i want to know the origin of the march
25th order where did it come from it
didn't come from
science there are reports that it came
from hospital lobbyists
and there might be a money trail and a
trail of corruption
and i believe ron kim he's a democrat
his
uncle died in a nursing home it's
personal for him
and he's been bullied and threatened by
this governor and he's been doing it for
far too long
and now it's time i do believe there is
bipartisan support
uh to get an investigation and perhaps
maybe even you know something criminal
down the line with this governor
one thing i would really like an answer
to donald trump built
three thousand a three thousand bed
hospital at the javits center that
remained 80 percent empty
he brought in the navy hospital ship he
manned these
these hospitals provided all the mass
the gowns the shields the gloves
everything that was needed
converted it all to covert 19 even
changed the ventilation systems
uh to do it again providing
everything 80 of those beds remained
empty
i'm trying to wrap my mind around why
why didn't he use them why didn't he
it was there for free and available to
him
correct and that's another question that
has never been answered and maybe this
investigation
will prove something and just breaking
tonight i want to tell you
uh some of the reporting from bill
hammond from the empire center
has shown that putting covet positive
patients into nursing homes
has statistically risen those numbers
and that would go against what the
governor has been saying
that it was the nursing home workers
that brought
the infection in do you believe there'll
be a massive
class action lawsuit here is it
something you and
other families are thinking about
we're talking about it at the very least
it would
it would get the ball rolling on getting
some information to us
something that we haven't had in almost
a year now
i'm sorry to every family that suffered
a loss here
and worse pandemics in 1917 and 18
and then to add bad decisions and not
own them
how do we learn to do better the next
time
he didn't listen to his own health
commission that recommended you need
15 783 ventilators he got none
just like the city of new york got none
they needed 10 000 more
you know so many mistakes made i'm sorry
thank you janice
when we